el mar Negro como escenario clave de
confrontación en la guerra el ministro
de relaciones exteriores de Ucrania
lanzó una controversial propuesta la
otan que encendió las alarmas en Rusia
el mar Negro es fundamental para hacer
que toda Europa sea pacífica y orientada
hacia el futuro Lamentablemente el mar
Negro también es una prueba de lo rápido
que pueden deteriorarse las cosas Si se
descuidan las amenazas culeva propone
integrar los sistemas de defensa aérea y
antimisiles ucranianos con los aliados
de La otan en el mar Negro y en el mar
Báltico este último controlado en su
mayoría por la otan y con el reciente
ingreso de Finlandia a la alianza
Rusia teme que ocurra lo mismo en el mar
Negro son marítima esencial para el
comercio y para su postura militar el
kremlin respondió a la propuesta de
culeva
el mar Negro nunca se convertirá en un
mar de la otan el mar es compartido por
todas las naciones litorales y debe ser
un mar de cooperación interacción y
seguridad la seguridad debe ser
indivisible
prueba la importancia estratégica al mar
Negro es el acuerdo de granos pactado
paralelamente por Rusia y Ucrania con la
ONU y Turquía la más reciente extensión
del pacto expirará el 18 de mayo y Rusia
se muestra renuente a extenderlo debido
a las restricciones que impiden la
salida de sus granos y fertilizantes
en el campo de batalla bacmut sigue
siendo epicentro de la guerra los rusos
afirman que controlan casi la totalidad
de la ciudad las tropas
aerotransportadas apoyan El Avance de
las tropas de asalto bloqueando el envío
de reservas del ejército ucraniano
abacmut y la posibilidad de una retirada
de las unidades enemigas
la caída de las ciudades de 70.000
habitantes antes de la guerra sería una
victoria simbólica para Moscú y le daría
más fácil acceso a urbes más grandes de
toniesk como kramatoros y eslovians